all right i'm not making it up we have
less smoke out there than we did
yesterday at this hour thank goodness
now we do have clouds there have been
some showers even some thunderstorms
around the utah arizona border off to
the east so sun is kind of hiding behind
that cloud those clouds right now the
wildfire smoke has been pushed from the
north to the southeast of us so we are
seeing kind of some haze off to the east
side but overall air quality is going to
be much better today i think you're
going to like that now we do
look for some areas with some moderate
dust just because the wind's going to
kick up some dust around town especially
open dirt lots in those areas so be
careful out in the rural areas look at
these 60 62 at mountains edge right now
we were looking for 60s this morning
because we knew that cold front would
make a difference it's even down to 57
at red rock and 43 up at kyle canyon 42
up in cedar city 55 in kingman we've got
60s in mesquite but wow indian springs
you're cool at 54 we know you're cool
anyway but you're really cool this
morning 57 in param and back to 20s up
in ely with 50 or 30 excuse me in
tonepaw 40s up in reno so this cold
front has been kicking up the northerly
winds between yesterday's southwest
winds and overnight northerly winds that
started just before midnight we've seen
25 to 30 mile per hour wind gusts and i
think we'll still see that off and on
through the day this cold front right on
top of us and around the front to the
north we've seen showers and sometimes
thunderstorms behind it is the cooler
air and we're going to enjoy the benefit
of that cooler air for a little while
all right so the flow is out of the
north sometimes the winds are out of the
north sometimes northeast and we'll keep
that through the day 83 today so morning
clouds give way to more sunshine in the
afternoon overnight we're back to 50s
and 60s to start off your thursday you
might want to pull out some long sleeves
just for the morning hours afternoons
beautiful mid 80s even to start off
friday to start off october and then
back to some warm low 90's sunday monday